welcome back continuing on from the last
video the rule of three if you haven't
seen that first go watch it we're now
we're going to talk about rule five and
why you would want to use this uh we're
just going to read it this is still from
the same site as last time in CVP rep
because the presence of user defined or
equals default or equals delete declared
Destructor copied Constructor or copy
assignment so notice that this is uh all
the stuff from the rule three if you're
using the rule of three you might want
to be following the rule five too so
observed because if you're uh declaring
a Destructor copy Constructor or copy
assignment operator it's going to
prevent implicit definition of move
Constructors and move assignment
operators so if you want move
Constructors and move assignment
operators
you must follow the rule of five because
uh yeah just I guess declaring these is
what breaks that
all right so any class for which move
semantics are desirable has to declare
all five special member functions and
well the first three we've already went
over
and in the rule of three
so these other two we just need to add
if you want to follow the rule of five
now of course you want to ask the
question do I need these do I want move
Constructors and move assignment
operators totally depends on your
software and your program and what
you're doing but if you want your class
to take ownership of memory then the
answer is probably yes because that's
essentially what the move is going to do
is it's going to say it's going to move
the memory in to this class well you can
think of it that way it doesn't it's not
exactly what it does that's how I think
of it all right so let's just run
through this here's a new class they're
calling the class rule five and they've
got the same data type as last time just
a care star they call C string that's
the private piece of data now they did
make one Improvement uh here you know in
the last one we went over they had a
Constructor that then called another
private Constructor in this one they've
just made it all public but it
essentially does the same thing as the
rule of three one you see when they when
you instantiate rule of five can if you
want pass in the data right away and
it's going to set that all up and this
sets it up with the mem copy so this is
doing a deep copy of whatever you're
passing and then we've got the same
deleter so essentially these are still
the same as the rule three so far uh
this one as well same as the rule of
three but here's where we add something
new a move Constructor so this is what
you'd need to add as you can see it's no
longer const this Constructor is no
longer const like the copy one was and
it's a double reference in its other so
the double reference is what really tell
tells it it's allowed to move all right
they also have no except no exceptions
allowed okay that's fine cool allows for
more optimizations yeah obviously you
probably already know this but you know
the move is a very efficient operation
it doesn't have to allocate it it
doesn't have to copy data it just it's
kind of like a construct in place it's
like the data is already here just point
the variable to it you know it's now
your variable move into place so here's
all they do they call their C string
their data type and they instantiate it
with a standard exchange we haven't
talked about exchange I'll talk about
real quick what it basically what it
does so exchange is going to take the
first argument and return its original
value so C string is going to end up
becoming this original value
and it's going to take that original
space and turn it into null pointer so
it's going to give you this other dot C
string and then set it the null pointer
basically
with just an exchange kind of a weird
way to do it but it works fine
especially if you want to you know no
one no one has control over this piece
of data anymore that you're moving in in
theory anyway other than your rule five
class so setting it to null pointer
after you do it is fine and you can go
look at this function if you want you
can just click on it here actually and
they've got some pretty decent data so
we'll just quickly talk about exchange
but
it's uh let's see here
yeah here's the here it is here's the
meat and potatoes basically so it makes
the type of your old value and use
standard move on object that so this is
the passed in object and then the other
thing is a new back so then it sets your
object the old one to whatever new value
via forward and then it Returns the old
value so that's uh that's the
implementation basically of Exchange
so basically it's just going to return
this first argument with a move and then
okay let's move on but yeah that's new
that's uh hope that makes sense if not
study it it's important to understand
that if your C plus plus programmer all
right rule of five operator okay copy
assignment this is the same as the rule
of three one basically for their equals
operator
but if you want to also be able to move
and not just copy you gotta make your
own and it's uh this one here we still
return the class by reference still an
equal operator of course but now no more
cons when we add double reference and
once again no accept for this move here
they're using Swap and a swap kind of
does what you think it does uh maybe a
little differently than you think but
essentially it's going to use the move
operation
um and move this other string the one
they passed in here into this one and
you can go look at the definition of
swamp if you want but there's also a lot
of overloads but essentially it just
does a move operation let's see where is
it here they don't really show the
implementation it's mostly
I don't know I guess I could go look at
a header but I'm not going to go through
all that it basically just switches
these types I believe or switches the
data there instantiating
all right and then it just returns to
class as required so pretty standard
there but once again swap is going to
use the move operations especially if
signature is correct and that's really
all you need to know so just get those
move semantics in with that rule of five
all right well that's going to do it for
this video maybe let me see if I could
just cover rule of zero yeah I think I'm
just gonna attack rule 0 onto this
because I don't think it's quite big
enough to be long enough for its own
video anyway we've got most of the
boilerplate out with the first episode
the rule three and then rule of five I
think is pretty straightforward just
adding those two move assignment uh
things and then rule of zero well
uh let's just read it all right that's
gonna be best classes that have custom
destructors copy slash move Constructors
copy slash move assignment operators
should deal exclusively with ownership
which follows the single responsibility
principle let's not get sidetracked into
that too much but
basically things need to manage their
memory and your programs stuff correctly
it's all that really means okay other
classes should not have to deal with
custom destructors copy slash move
Constructors or copy move assignment
operators so basically what we're saying
here is only your classes that handle
this these special case instantiating
and uh resource acquisition and stuff
like that those are the ones that should
have all this custom stuff all the other
ones so just be default so
that's basically what it means is don't
do it if you don't have to this rule
also appears in the C plus plus core
guidelines as if you can avoid defining
default operations do
and they've got a little example here
and I'm not sure what this is supposed
to show let's have a look okay this
really isn't much it's just a single
copy Constructor so I didn't mean to
click on that it's just a single copy
Constructor for their data piece what
they which they've now decided should be
a string in this article rather than a
care star but okay
okay let's read on when a base class is
intended for polymorphic use its
Destructor may have been declared
virtual public and virtual as you've
seen we've done on a lot of these
episodes
this blocks implicit moves and
depreciates implicit copies and so the
special member functions have to be
declared as defaulted so a little yeah
little changes here if you're doing
polymorphic stuff so if the destructor
was declared public and virtual it's
going to block moves
so special member functions have to be
declared as defaulted now what's the
problem with this well however this
makes the class prone to slicing which
is a why polymorphic classes often
defined copy as deleted which leads to
the following generic wording for the
rule of five if you define or delete any
default operation Define or delete them
all
now notice that this is specific to
default operations so and you may have
already that may have already sank in
but just in case it hasn't I'll say it
here in the finale this right here is
not a default operation so we're not
defining any default operations this is
fine with the rule of zero
the default operation would be like an
empty Constructor you know the one that
takes nothing that would be one of the
default ones so
that's why I think I think I'm
understanding this correctly because
this is a copy Constructor but it's not
one of the default ones now this one
these other ones like this one from the
rule of five this is a default because
of this equals like you can call rule
five and uh initialize it with nothing
and that's legal so that's why this is a
default one is because you can call this
with nothing you cannot call this one
with nothing this needs an equal
something on it to be able to be called
with no arguments so just the way C plus
plus works and same with up here they
are declaring one of the default ones so
I think I'm understanding that correctly
if you have information otherwise always
feel free to leave a comment uh some of
the stuff gets complicated and sometimes
I say things a little uh out of order or
wrong just wrong sometimes so I
appreciate Corrections of course if they
are needed all right well that's going
to do it for this uh episode in this
little series about the rule of three
five and zero hopefully this helps you
in your coding in one way or another and
uh yeah just want to say I appreciate
you guys thanks for watching and for any
of all support it means a lot peace out